Đại Loan Trung Quốc, phía trên Washington, Tục Rệ Loan lên trở thành tâm giữ của tàm loạn sau khi sật lượng
làng bất đất chắn của một hồi trường nước, tào tăng trị lũ sức rồi, của Châu Kỳ Cộ Lấn và nhìn chiếm như quân lượng.
Một lượng kêu ra hệ từ ngày 2,5 tán chiến, diễn phung đông đại Loan, một dân cửa thử thật,
bính chữ sật lượng, thình thành các hồ chắn từ nhìn, kiểu bớt, lất chắn xuống, kiến mới hoàn người trên mạc,
và nhìn một khán mất tích.
Nó rồi, mấy dẫn của Hoan Trung Quốc, phía trên tình thành hại và gà đêm cho lượng của Hồn,
cho nó kỳ báo của Châu Kỳ này, báo của Hồn vụi linh xa kiếp của Tên xe hoàn,
báo rộn chíng thật.
Tại không công, báo ràng ra xa cũng để lại hục quán,
ở đây, đến nhất xấu mi hàng người để bị thương.
Hằng trong người phải xa tán, đến nơi chua đánh tảm tươi,
rất là những vùng của báo.
Các nghĩa hàng, thử dụng các lượng, đúng thích hừng rộn,
được kiến mi vớt.
Để không phải gà đình.
Rồi toàn bột tôn bột bị xan phòng, sống biển chán thang ở bếp.
Chúng tôi chỉ còn cách sòn dẹp và mất đầu lại từ đầu.
Bột hạt trị sha mà bên vào.
Ờ, chúng tôi đã lục.
Tất cả thành phố công nghệ thân quyền tình còn đông.
Các công nhân đang tích thực sận dài kí đồ.
Quả thông cất tuyên đường nợ đồ.
Sau khi cần báo đi qua.
Trình đó, chỉ quyền tình còn đông cho biết.
Đất sự tăng 2 phải mì sấu trường người và vùng mua yển.
Đông thời yêu cầu trường học, dừng nghiệp,
tại ý nhất mười thành phố, tăng nừng mà đầu.
Tất cả chuyên ra, suy tăng thoát của xíu áo răng ra,
đất lời kinh báo với sự mông mạnh của các bột tị vệnh viện cho á,
trước tình tại thực đồ ăn.
Sức giống mạnh, mưa lượng và quá trình tăng tất bất thường trên vùng về lắm.
Trời thấy các thành phố như lông công thông quyền hay manila,
tình chuẩn bị kí lượng, cập nhật quy trận xây dự.
Bất nên cao khả năng ứng vỏ để hạn trị thị thịt hại,
thì những cơn báo giữ rồi trong đường lài.